as far as my resume you you don't know
me but you know tigger and winnie the
pooh i think it goes something like this
but i can only do it for a small
smackerel of honey and tigger don't play
with decorates tiggers are wonderful
things the tops are made of rubber the
bottom of the middle of the springs you
got to pay for the rest i'm getting with
you
[Music]
well you know the way i got into the
industry i mean i guess i was kind of uh
doing research my whole life because i'd
be sitting in the back of the classroom
and
you know i thought it was time to break
out a dolphin i don't want to say i was
the class clown i was the class wit
because it sounds better some of the
characters i play as a voice actor i dig
my orders directly from jafar princess
and all i want you to do is
trust in me
the women like a man with a big bad part
some kind of yeah
come here you little write-off
people said well which one's most like
you and i probably dark wing duck cause
he's a wise guy well i am the terror
that flaps in the night i am the bug
that splatters across the windshield of
crime i am darkwing duck
what could be more important than a
little something to eat
well you know as far as uh performing
poo you have to be true to the character
well i always say that pooh sees the
world through honey-colored glasses
not a bad way to go
somebody or something has found my honey
i i jokingly say that i'm winnie the
pooh and the auntie poo because i'm the
tasmanian devil
that's
[Music]
like having a little trouble a lot of
times my agent will get in touch with me
and there'll be a special needs a
little boy a little girl we're on the
telephone and they're talking to pooh or
tigger
well hello there billy
[Music]
[Applause]
but his response was it's just so cute
he's in the world you know tigger was
alive and
talking to him to know that you can
bring him into
smileville and and where everything's
happy and you're you know it's
it's just a blessing and a half i i
never take it for granted honestly the
most rewarding part is seeing people's
reactions and hearing stories about how
this one song got them through
uh tough times and they they'll go back
and they'll listen to wherever you are a
song that winnie the pooh song
cause without you i'm totally lost i'm
grateful grateful every day
[Music]
you